oh the ground is rocky
okay so i'm here with what's your name
chess master right
uh maxime has the largest youtube
channel in russian
for chess um and
we've we've played like once online i
think yeah
but uh i think it's been a while so good
luck
good luck okay
it's a russian in russia but it's also
staffer gambit in russia
yeah i can't i told him i told him
i can't help myself we're in the cloud
[Applause]
okay don't want to hurt me
let's have some buzz whoa
oh my god this is a novelty
i really love to mess things up i like
to make things messy
oh here you can't
that's okay
to do this not entirely sure
i want to be more sure
i'm going to play safe
it's deadly lost oh the game is just
beginning
i hope oh it's
playing very well
oh so the grub was a distraction
you think uh you are weak yeah
yeah i was underestimating you yeah
exactly once you place grub
yeah like okay maybe he doesn't know
anything
but now i see that's not the kiss
i'll play group in this next game
it sounds like a threat
you know i thought i will try to play
rook odds but now i don't think i should
it's one of my favorite things
it's more fun and uh
yeah you could also play blindfolded
yeah
you just ask why i'm not playing
blindfolded yeah
i appreciate my my ability to see the
beauty around us
but also the ugliness of this position
is always
very good oh it's very good yeah
hmm
[Music]
we play with increments yeah there is
increment yeah
no dirtiness no flagging
oh so bad
russian power
yeah if you want to trash talk me in
russian go right ahead
i can trash talk you in english
is
my great grandparents are from russia oh
yaha too borsch
i'll get you boris tonight yeah oh
really
i'll match you for boris tonight i've
had boris the last three nights
she only can buy bush she can't cook
bullish can you make boris
like all female professional chess
players i do not cook
first question on the date do we make
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh finally it came and your pawns are so
immaculate
yeah i was thinking when this will come
how do you say immaculate in russian
[Music]
inaccurate immaculate
like perfect but in a sense like
how do you say that too perfect
yes blistacea wonderful
oh my god
[Music]
don't worry be happy okay
it's hard to be happy when you're
squeezing me though here comes the sound
that's amazing
view i'm talking about though talking
about eric
i want a
[Music]
we're
chess youtuber it's my time i'm staying
alive
it's about to get down
can i say um it's my time
oh no my queen type train
type train we start hiding well this is
for youtube um
oh no my hype
i think i should
it's time time for what
pain it's time to win
okay i'm not gonna flag
i'm gonna resist as much as possible
okay i'm confusing him at least
oh no
i flagged and i knocked over the kings
be
yeah